Hello Freak bitches where you saw a lot
of the hypocrites was in the first few
days of this Harvey
Weinstein, please. Yeah,
and you know what, men at the end of
the week, they were all fucked him.
Discuss those cause they all fucking
knew about it. How they all knew.
They all knew about it for years and
none of they all want to raise their
fucking head. You know what bro?
When hobbies was given them movies,
nobody was complaining. Yeah. Well
I've, I've heard nobody was complaining.
Nobody was going to
play in it from a girl.
She was saying that a Harvey Weinstein
gave them all careers. I was like, wow,
that's a crazy, crazy argument. The one,
two of the chicks tank them in the
ask us now you're going to acute.
Listen to leave me the fuck alone.
The ones that really need the smack at
the mouth of the guys that came out and
said,
I got molested once I got got
touched on a party one time.
We live for that shit. We live for
somebody to touch a fucking Dick.
You know what I'm saying? We're not going
to go to therapy. We don't say nothing.
Somebody grabs you dick. He just
fucking smoked gay guy and whatever.
Everybody needs a break from time to
time you'd have a lot of gay guys suck a
Dick with ice cubes and then mum, it's
a party. You know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
But I had a friend one time that he let
anybody suck his dick. Anybody, anybody,
anybody who wants to suck his dick did
suck is yummy. I'm sticking really.
And one day he was telling me about
fucking get his dick sucked by a gay guy
with ice cubes in his mouth. I nearly
fucking died. He just let the guy do it.
Yeah. If he goes fuck it.
What was the conversation?
He was telling me how his mouth was cold
and all this shit and that was fucking
dying.
I couldn't believe it.
They couldn't get the guy
while he's sucking his dick,
I don't want to know about that.
She would want to know.
But you wanted to know about the guy
getting his dick sucked by a dude with ice
cubes in his mouth. I mean, why not? What
he told me is watching it. First of all,
when he told me this story, I was young.
I had never heard that story before.
I was like 18 he goes out of
the fucking guy. Suck my Dick.
Wouldn't time with ice cube one time,
but if it was so good,
why don't I keep going?
Yeah.
It's tough to find somebody who was
suck a dick with ice cubes in them math,
unless you give them the small 50 I
think once you put it out there you could
put that flag up if he can't come.
That was the funniest thing when
that crazy bitch from Superman,
cause she popped up like eight days later.
Harvey took his dick out one time and I
told him put that back in your pants and
crazy chick from superman. Which
one? What's that chick? That's crazy.
All the one that was hiding in
the bushes when they found her.
She had no teeth at one. What the Hell
is her name? What's her name? Superman.
Christopher Reeve, right? No, the other
one wasn't superman. Christopher Reeve.
Early Superman, right? Yeah.
It was the one with Dean Cain who was the
crazy and Kane who was the one in that.
Margot kidder is crazy, right?
Yeah, so this was the other one.
Then the other one month,
you're talking about the one who was in
superman with Dean Cain to TV show. Yeah,
maybe. It wasn't really pretty girls
name. Terri [inaudible] her name.
She got to talk in the mic butter.
She was on a TV show.
She was in desperate housewives
too, right? Yeah. No, it wasn't her.
I had an ex girlfriend of mine get so
mad when I was talking about how pretty
she was. Let me see. Superman actress
found frightened in the bushes. Yeah,
that was in six Margo kid or yeah,
she went crazy.
47 year old Canadian born actress. Best
known. You know what? That's the thing.
Once you hit like late forties and you
one of those actresses and they stopped
calling and you are already
crazy and the pressure builds up,
she'd cut off her own hair with a
razor blade and attempt to alter her
appearance.
A Glendale Police Sargent Rick Young said,
Oh boy,
she's taken to Olive View Medical Center
for a 72 hour psychiatric evaluation.
They a spared 71 hours and 50
minutes by just bringing her to me
all the way. Yeah, that bitch
is crazy. What happened to you?
Have you had that with Corey
Feldman though? I don't know.
He apparently got arrest, all that
thing. I made a joke and people get met.
We did. They got mad, but it wasn't them
getting mad as me getting mad at myself.
What was the Joe?
Uh,
he was wearing a really small jacket
while he's doing this performance at minor
league baseball game and he was doing
like this Michael Jackson thing,
but the jacket was so small it goes,
is that a jacket he was wearing when he
was getting diddled when he was a little
kid? And I was like, why
did I joke around that?
It was just trying to make Greg laugh
and I just, I said something that I was,
and then afterwards when I saw it,
especially out of context,
I was very disappointed in myself.
He wants 10 million to
fucking suppose pedophile.
He saw that he's out of his mind, I
think. Um, I don't think he, first of all,
he never said that Michael Jackson
did anything to him. He was,
he said Michael Jackson didn't,
but he said that there's
a lot of pedophilia in
Hollywood and he wants to make
some sort of a movie on it,
which I'm sure there's a lot
of pedophilia in Hollywood,
but like this idea that
people trying to kill him.
You were saying that people are
trying to run him over and said, well,
isn't that what we're saying? I watched
the video full. I have a hard time.
I felt bad. If they wanted to kill,
hold up. If they wanted to kill him,
he'd be dead. Yeah. Tried
to hit him. That's not real.
See this is like weird paranoia shit.
Let me tell you something.
If they want to kill you,
you're dead and it's not going to
be trucks trying to run you over.
It's going to be a guy out of nowhere,
shoots you in the head and gets in his
car and no one's going to know who he is
and no one's going to catch him because
they're going to hire a professional,
like this idea that someone's gonna like
miss him with a car and then they're
chasing them or running them down. I find
that very hard. I mean, it's possible,
but I find it very hard to believe.
I always think that like if someone
is a very powerful man, like,
like I don't know if the Clintons
ever whacked anybody, but if they did,
they whacked those fucking people.
Like that one guy. That was the big,
the big conspiracy theory about the guy
who released all this stuff to wikileaks,
the denim DNC guy. Seth rich. Yeah.
They killed that motherfucker.
Whoever did it,
whether he was killed because some
random person decided to shoot him in the
back in the middle of the night and
not steal his watch or his phone or his
wallet.
Whether it's that or whether it's,
what Julian Assange from wikileaks said
is that there's consequences to leaking
information to wikileaks because that's
what they were saying and people were
saying, look, this is another one in the
Clinton body count people and then this,
you know,
giant conspiracy theories about how many
people the Clinton's have had killed.
I don't know if that's true or not.
I have zero information,
but I do know when people want you
dead, you're dead. You're dead.
When they're real people like that,
that are real killers and evil fucks.
There's a lot of people that
have been killed like Putin.
If Putin wants you dead,
you get shot on TV in front of
everybody and nothing happens.
No one goes to jail. No one
gets caught. You're just dead.
That's the type of people we're talking
about. So this, you know, I just,
I have a hard time believing that.
Like someone's getting like barely missed
by a car. That's like some movie shit.
Like they were coming after me,
but I drive to the bushes at the last
minute and now I'm hiding in a motel
somewhere and I can't tell you where.
But if you give me $10 million,
I want to make a movie.
You don't want,
I feel bad for Corey from when you see
that. When you see that performance.
I mean that,
but he's a nice kid and stuff.
You could see Holly was
just fucking made a mockery.
Like they just beat him up though. Well
he grew up on TV in the movie. Yeah.
They beat him up. Roll up in the movies.
You, you know you don't have a childhood.
Who the fuck do you know who I named?
One that made it through that
meat grinder of growing up famous.
That's not completely fucking crazy.
Name one name one look,
Miley Cyrus might've gotten out of it
better than any of them. She's like,
her new album's really good. I loose,
he's fucking town. She's great, Bro.
Don't have gives you those ones that
she's up on the hill and Tennessee with a
little band and this thing of outside
in the mountains near cover of Jolene,
Jolene, Jolene, that thing. She's great.
Okay.